ah yes been trying to potty train Calvin
which is really [__] hilarious uh he
just
he'll go he'll go on the little potty
you know we got that little potty and
[__]
for him
uh I [__] in there too it's a mess no I
don't and um
he has a little potty and he sits on it
and he waits to pee and he's just like
waiting and then he'll he'll go it'll go
and it'll jump up and as he jumps up
he'll go I did it and piss all over the
floor also and I'm like uh dude you're
doing such a good job dude you are doing
such a good job but you got to stay
there on the on the toilet and he does
again he does a little bit more stands
up as he's I did it and I'm like I got
piss all over me I'm just like you're
doing such a good job dude
you are doing such a good job you gotta
stay on there I'm pooping I'm poop I'm
like that's actually pee but you're
doing it dude
and then and then he's like I have to
poop and he goes on there sits on the
toilet for 25 minutes doesn't poop and
I'm just wasting time dude but I'm not
though because you know I'm teaching
them how to party how to be potty
trained but it's so [__] cute and so
funny dude I'll actually sit there with
him all [__] day dude I don't get
bored we chat we talk about [__]
different things I mean mostly it's
[__] because he's leading it but
like dude it's stuff that you know what
it's important to him how about that how
about maybe that's what he needs
so if he wants to talk about [__]
purple crayons for way too long which he
does sometimes we talk about purple
crayons if you want to say it's crayon
day even though he's using a highlighter
then you know what it's [__] crayon
day dude
um but he'll just sit there he hasn't
pooped in there yet but um you know
he'll pee in there sometimes and we'll
take the thing and we'll walk it over to
the toilet dump it out and then it'll go
I'll go buy pee pee
and then it'll run back over
and I can run back over to the toilet
um but yeah dude
I went in last night he he was he was up
till I mean I put him in bed at maybe
nine something
maybe ten you know he sleeps late
because he's comic hours
um but
he uh
he he didn't have his blanket he was
still bucking around for until like 12
30. it's been two hours and I'm like
[__] I I said Christian I was like
should we [__] go
should I put put a blanket in there and
she was like yeah yeah but the one
blanket that he likes is the only
blanket he'll allow in the bed I mean
he's so me already he's two and a half
and just like he's got to have the
[__] one blanket and she's like it's
in the car and I was like oh okay I'll
go out get a car and get it bring it I
bring it in and say hey buddy he says Hi
I said do you want your blanket and he
says yes
and I put the blanket on him and I said
how you doing you okay and he said yes
and I said
do you want me to uh get in there with
you and sleep in the crib and I was kind
of like just saying it and he said
I said you do you want me to come in he
says yes and so I move so he moves over
I go in in the crib and I'm sleeping
with him actually we have a picture of
it we can put it on the uh
on the video and uh and then I and then
I wait and then I and then I'm I'm there
for about 10 seconds and he's looking at
me in the eyes and he goes like this
go away
Stick Dude and I said oh you want me out
and he says go away
foreign
left
[Music]
y crazy
you're crazy